[Music]
all right despite uh strong resistance
from Biden's allies Republicans are now
pushing for answers in the hunter Biden
investigations the IRS whistleblowers
alleging political bias in the hunter
Biden probe are set to testify in front
of lawmakers next week this is going to
be Blockbuster and Senior officials at
the doj the IRS Secret Service are in
talks with House Republicans about them
sitting for interviews meanwhile the doj
confirmed the lead attorney in the
hunter Biden probe David Weiss is
willing to meet with the house Judiciary
Committee quote at an appropriate time
what when hell freezes over here with
reaction former acting U.S attorney
general Matt Whitaker and New York Post
reporter John Levine Matt let me start
with you they have been reluctant they
have been resistant they have been
uncooperative they didn't want to hand
over the 1023 form for example Witnesses
have not been forthcoming number two uh
you know we can look at Christopher Ray
yesterday or earlier this week and what
do we see him duck Dodge weave obfuscate
so they're not Cooperative with the FBI
they have not been Cooperative with the
doj at all have they no they haven't
it's good to be with you Sean and just
like the hunter Biden case taking five
years to investigate before these weak
misdemeanor charges and a and a
throwaway you know agreement uh is was
made you know this uh truth they don't
want it to come out they're trying to
get their stories straight they have
these two IRS agents with a lot of
credibility that are going to testify
consistent with what they've previously
testified which is this investigation
was spiked by the highest levels of
Biden appointed doj officials and they
just don't want that story to get out
and John my argument is this judge
should not sign off on the sweetheart
deal that the prosecutors gave Hunter
Biden especially in light of so much
more that we know I think the court
needs to give time for this to all
percolate and these IRS whistleblowers
to tell their story and that has got to
be reconfigured at that point in my view
what are your what's your take well that
that's certainly sort of a wrench in the
Machinery that not a lot of people are
talking about is Hunter's plea deal has
to be approved by the judge and we it's
it's far from clear to me that that
necessarily will happen and part of his
plea deal also requires that he stay
clean and stay off of drugs which raises
you know new questions about obviously
drugs were just found in the white house
and we don't know who brought them but
we do know that an active cocaine addict
has been staying at the White House so
there's there's a real political
imperative to not necessarily wait a
minute here and John we also know Karine
Jean-Pierre la to the country when she
said that the bidens weren't there the
Friday before the weekend when they
found the cocaine and Joe and we know
it's an irresponsible question to even
ask that so I'm a very early responsible
host right you know you're right I am I
plead guilty uh Matt Whitaker when when
you hear about all this being covered up
and even David Weiss John Solomon
reported this week approved the
indictment on tax felony charges for
Hunter
and they didn't even his own Department
approved it and then they still buried
it and lowered it to misdemeanor charges
and and the gun charges a joke from the
people that lecture every American about
their second amendment rights
yeah as a former U.S attorney and you
know senior doj official I see a
designer plea deal when I and I know
that's exactly what happened here you
know they let the statute run on the
most serious years so that they couldn't
bring those charges which would have
been felonies and then they have these
misdemeanor charges coupled with this
agreement uh to not offend again but you
know uh what was just mentioned is
really important because this plea deal
if approved by the judge is going to
require Hunter Biden to be drug tested
on a regular basis and we'll see if you
know it follows through with that and
then if he can comply with those terms
going forward
John how do you see this ending you know
what's going to save us and I never
thought I would say this paper
paper the federal government is one
thing they can do is generate Reams and
reams of paper if David Weiss tried to
become a special counsel and he was
denied there will be a paper trail if he
tried to bring charges against Hunter
Biden in other jurisdictions and he was
denied there'll be a paper trail for
that too and that is going to be the
only objective way to really suss out
who is telling the truth here and who is
not you know at a future date
undisclosed I don't think the doj wants
him to testify before Congress because
in that moment that would be a perjury
trap potential if you're right anyway
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else